Hello and welcome back. As you've seen
previously, an operating system has to protect the
integrity of the hardware resources it manages while
providing the services to the applications. Thus it
has many responsibilities and a variety of functional
components that provide these services. But how should
all these pieces fit together? At least some
of the components of the operating system will
have to run in a privileged mode
of the processor architecture that allows them access
to hardware. But must the whole operating
system have this privilege? Also, if an application
would benefit from having certain services, for
example, memory management handled in a particular way.
Can we personalize the services to suit
the needs of the application? In other words,
can we make the operating system flexible in
terms of the policies it implements for the
services offered by it? Does this flexibility have
to come at the price of performance and or
safety of the operating system? These are some
of the questions we will try to answer in
this course module. In this course module, we
will learn the basics of operating system structuring issues.
We will use SPIN and Exokernel as case
studies of two closely-related approaches to providing extensibility
of operating system services. We will then study
a microkernel-based approach as well, using L3 microkernel.